The Frohe Weihnachten! Frohe Weihnachten, I guess. Ein Weihnachtsinterview von niemandem, der Weihnachten hasst. Ja, finde ich gut, dass man da subtil musikalisch auch einbauen kann, dass man nicht so begeistert ist.
Felix, oder? Ja, vielen Dank, Felix. Feierst du dieses Jahr alleine, wäre jetzt meine Frage, weil es klingt ein bisschen so, als hätte er so eigene Emotionen eingebracht. Und was ich auch nicht schlecht finde, also warum es bei mir erstmal so ein bisschen so einen ironischen Klang mitgebracht hat, war ja, weil im Hintergrund die ganze Zeit rhythmisch die Glöckchen am Start waren. Und ich weiss nicht, wie es dir geht, aber ich stelle mir immer, und deswegen finde ich auch so Orchestermusiken als Soundtrack, wie damals bei Star Wars, haben halt so einen richtigen Impact, weil wenn alle gemeinsam machen, hat es halt irgendwie so was Selbstbewusstes und das macht den Film noch selbstbewusster. Und ich finde, weil man sich immer vorstellt, dass alles, das ganze Orchester steht gerade so dahinter. Und ich stelle mir immer so ein bisschen, stellt man sich ja dann so bildlich die Musiker vor. Und bei diesem Glöckchen kann ich, stell ich mir diesem traurigen Menschen vor, der dann da aber steht und diesen Glockenkranz hat und rhythmisch, weil das kein Instrument, was man traurig und Tambourin, kann man auch nicht traurig bedienen, weißt du? Ich glaube, ich würde in den klassischen Hochzeits-,
in den klassischen Beerdigungsmärschen und so
einfach selten auch benutzen.
Glöckchen hat man nicht, einen Schellenkranz.
Brauchst du keine Glöckchen, Schellenkranz oder so was,
brauchst du einfach nicht, Shaker, wird einfach selten gebraucht.
Vielleicht aber ist es auch eine Aussage über diese Musiker,
dass sie einfach sagen, nein, ich will einfach nur positive Sachen spielen,
ich will shaken, ich will den Rhythmus
und ich will nicht dann irgendwie zur Mondscheinsonate eingeladen werden. Trotzdem vielen Dank an Felix. Vielen Dank. Ansonsten vielen Dank für dieses weihnachtliche Intro. Wir sind natürlich in Weihnachtsstimmung, egal ob wir alleine oder in Gemeinsamkeit feiern, die Weihnachtsstimmung ist da. Wir sind bei euch, Florentin und Stefan sind unsere Namen. Korrekt, richtig. Habe ich in der Moderationsschule gelernt, soll man dann am Anfang der Folge unterbringen irgendwann. In den ersten 30 Minuten sollte man das sagen. Genau, Stefan Tietze, kannst du Tietze nochmal buchstabieren? TZE tatsächlich das auch. Ja, tatsächlich, weil wir haben viele Einsendungen, die deinen Namen so ein bisschen krumm kriegen, die da so ein bisschen verwegstabeln, verburgseln. Und deswegen müssen wir das nochmal ganz klar zurren, bitte. Ich glaube ja, es ist meine Theorie, dass die meisten Weihnachtsgeschenke nicht ankommen, weil man meinen Namen falsch schreibt. Nicht, weil man dann doch eine relativ geringe Reichweite hat. Irgendwo im Nordpol liegt noch ein ganzer Berg Weihnachtsgeschenke für dich rum vom Weihnachtsmann, die jedes Jahr unzustellbar zurückkommen. Ja, an die ganzen Stephan-Tietzes mit IH und IE und so, die man sich, Oder vielleicht gibt's die auch, und die werden immer reichlich beschenkt und denken,
was das sind für tolle Sachen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Viele selbstgebastelte Sachen, viele Briefe, viele Älfchen.
Also der Tietze da draußen, der auch die ganzen Mails bekommt, die ganzen Einladungen zu Filmabende,
die du dir ja ständig bekommst und rigoros ablehnst.
Rigoros zerreißt in meinen grossen Kamin-Sims.
Das ist eigentlich ein grosser Nachteil an der Mail, dass du die Zusendung nicht zerreissen kannst.
Wir haben uns auch ein paar Worte, die wir jetzt haben. und rigoros ablehnst ... Rigoros zerreißt und meinen grossen Kamin-Sims. Das ist eigentlich ein grosser Nachteil an der Mail, dass du die Zusendung nicht zerreissen kannst. Früher alles am Mail ... Ja, aber das hat nicht denselben Flair, wenn du so eine Nachricht liest und du sitzt in einem Herrenhaus vorm Kamin und liest, hallo Stefan, ich wollte wissen, ob ihr mir das unterschrieben und du einfach ratsch, ratsch, ratsch, sag Kamin. Weihnachten ist ja in mir, es läuft ganz, ganz laut, irgendwie so Karl Orff oder so und ich sitze in meinem Bauchimmer Rollstuhl vorm Kamin mit deinem Bordeaux-roten Tages, wie nennt man das, Mantel, Tagesmantel, Hausmantel und hab dann in der Hand ungeöffnete Briefe, die ich so im, sagen wir mal, 20-Sekunden-Takt in das Feuer schmeiße. Ungeöffnet, ja. Ungeöffnet. Dann schallt Karl auch durchs Haus und nachher kommt jemand und sieht nach mir. Und dann werden immer so neue Päckchen Briefe angerichtet. Herr Tietze, hier sind neue Einsendungen. Robert aus Wiesbaden, die Flammen nehmen dich! Aber ich finde es sogar, ich würde nicht besprechen, ich finde es hat sogar was bisschen Feinseligeres, es erst auszudrucken und dann Drucker frisch noch in den Kamin zu schmecken. Die Tinte ist kaum getrocknet, schon wurde sie von den Flammen verschlungen. Hättest du gern Kamin? Ich hätte erst mal gern Drucker. Das ist erst mal für mich die erste Hürde.
Das ist toll, ich muss nämlich immer ganz peinlich, wenn ich Dinge ausdrucken will, bei Rocket Beans Entertainment GmbH muss ich immer hin zu irgendeinem Volontär oder Redakteur gehen und sagen, hast du einen Druckerzugang? Und er muss sich immer dem die Dokumente geben, was dann immer so super peinliche Liebesbriefe sind, wo ich dann sagte, ja, will man jetzt wirklich das Pergament mit Tinte haben? Nee, Mail ist zu unpersönlich, machen wir ein Mittelding, machen wir einen ausgedruckten Textdokument. Das verschicke ich dann, da wird dann nochmal Parfüm draufgesprüht und das muss halt alles ausgedruckt werden. Und deswegen ist es immer sehr unangenehm, die ganzen Sachen auszudrucken. Ich glaube, das Peinlichste, was ich hier hatte, war wirklich ein Kniefall von meinem Vermieter, bei dem es so ist, dass es heißt, ja, wollen Sie Ihre Miete verlängern, bitte melden Sie sich bis zum XY-Tag. Und den hatte ich zwei Monate überschritten. Und dann wollte ich aber da trotzdem weiter wohnen bleiben und wollte trotzdem die Wohnung weiter haben. Und dann musste ich wirklich so einen Brief schreiben, den ich seit der Schule nicht mehr geschrieben habe. So ein lieber Herr Brankenbrüller. Sehr geehrter, wenn man auch so tief in die Vokabelkiste greifen musste. Sehr geehrter Brankenbrüller, ich falle vor Ihnen zu Füssen. Ich drücke mein Gesicht in den Staub und küsse Ihnen die Füsse. Ich bin ihre Nichts. Ich schwöre dich, ich bin nichts. Ich will nicht, dass sie mich so sehen. Sie wenden sich den Charme ab, aber leiden sie mir für ein paar Momente ihr Gehör. Nehmen sie den mitgesandten Raben als ihr Mitgift. Und ja, wirklich Kniefall, es war für mich ein hartes Jahr wie für uns alle. Und die aktuelle Situation... Automatisch wird man auch so Vokabulär, so gut 150 Jahre zurückgeworfen. Ja, absolut. Je schlimmer die Situation, desto weiter in die Vergangenheit redet. Desto mehr Mittelalter schwingt mit im Text. Ja, ich liege in Scharm da nieder und bin voll ins ihrer Gnade ausgeliefert, Lord Brunkenbrüller. Und man denkt, holy shit, da ist richtig scheiße, die Kacke ist am dampfen. Ja, ist das eine Fanfare? Ach du Scheiße, jetzt kommt sie dicke. Und dann habe ich den abgeschickt und den, der war so peinlich, das war so wirklich ein Kniefall, so ein Ja und das, ich war ja lange nicht da und konnte den Brief nicht aus meinem Briefkasten holen, alle, alle Register gezogen. Klar. Und den musste auch ein Volontär für mich ausdrücken, das war mir so unangenehm, weil das wirklich, da will man nicht gesehen werden. Es ist schon peinlich genug, Kniefall vor jemandem zu machen. Du hast den aber, Moment, du hast den dann ausgedruckt, um ihn dann wirklich abzuschicken per Post, per Briefpost. Per Briefpost. Gute alte Briefpost. Anders, die man verwechseln könnte mit allen anderen Formen der Post, die wir ja kennen. Das ist die Briefpost gewählt. Ich habe die Briefpost gewählt und die ist es dann geworden, meine Wahl der Übertragung. Das ist halt so ein Oldschool-Meeting, wo man das halt brieft. Wie man Briefe abschickt, habe ich komplett, weiß ich nicht mehr. Hast du Briefmarken bei dir zu Hause? Nein. Null. Ich muss jedes Mal googeln, wo soll die Adresse hin, wo muss ich hin, wie muss man den, muss man den anschneiden mit einem Frisbee, in welche Himmelsrichtung werfe ich diesen Brief, wie funktioniert das alles, muss ich jedes Mal googeln und Google sagt mittlerweile, come on, ich zeige dir jetzt, irgendwann sagt Google auch, weißt du was, ich zeige dir das jetzt nicht mehr an. Du googelst das jede Woche seit Jahren. Das kann doch nicht sein, dass das nicht drin ist bei dir. Was ich auch nicht verstehe, man sagt ja uns zum Beispiel, gut, leidiges altes Thema, füttert keine Tiere, damit die Tiere nicht verlernen, wie man jagt, wie man jagt, wie man jä jagt, so und Google ist uns ja auch überlegen, machen wir uns nichts vor. Ja. Als gros ist uns Google überlegen.
Und warum sagt Check Google nicht, dass man uns hier und da Informationen verweigern sollte, weil wir sonst nicht mehr auf eigenen Beinen stehen können.
Ich kann nicht mehr auf eigenen Beinen stehen, niemand von uns kann mehr auf eigenen, unsere Gesellschaft kann nicht mehr auf eigenen Beinen stehen.
Du, Navigations-App, wirklich vom Supermarkt nach Hause, wo die App auch sagt, du fährst den Weg jeden Tag. Du kennst den Weg. Du kennst den Weg. Das müsste eigentlich so eine Fehlermeldung sein. Glaub mir, du kennst den Weg. Ich bin für dich da, wenn du dich arg verläuft jetzt, verläuftest. Ja, wenn du wirklich da in der Wallachai unterwegs bist, dann melde dich. Aber du kennst den Weg. Auch mal so ein bisschen Selbstvertrauen zu sprechen, so hey, du brauchst mich gar nicht,, du kennst den Weg. Ja, ab und zu mal zumindest die Hälfte an Informationen weglassen, so dass man mal sagt, pass auf, ich gebe da einen Hinweis Richtung Netto. Ja. So, oder dass man mal so gen Norden. Ich wüsste aber auch nicht mehr, wo Norden ist, ehrlich gesagt. Ich wüsste auch generell so navigieren und alte Strassenkarten zu haben und so, das ist mir komplett fremd. Aber gut, ich denke, da muss Google auch ein bisschen was lernen. Ich habe ein Geschenk für Felix. Oh, sehr gut. Felix, der Komponist unseres Intros. Ein Du-Akkord. Oh, das ist schön. Welchen, du schenkst ja jedes Jahr einen Akkord. Einen Du-Akkord. Welcher ist es dieses Jahr? G. Oh, ein schöner, ein schöner. Mit der Beste. Ist gefährlich, weil viele haben den schon. Da musst du natürlich aufpassen, aber kann man auch gut zurückgeben. Ist ein Klassiker, aber ich sage mal, einen guten G-Akkord habe ich auch doppelt gerne. Aber du bist auch bestimmt gerne in Musikläden, oder? So Instrumente und sowas? Ja. Mein Lieblingsmusikinstrument ist ja der Dirigierstock, den man ja auch kaufen kann in Musikläden. Du kannst eine Gitarre kaufen, E-Bass, B-Bass, aber du kannst halt auch einfach, und das stelle ich mir immer gut vor, in diese Kiste greifen und einfach so 20 Dirigierstöcke kaufen. Jeder kostet eine Mark. Und dann steht auch da so, wie neben den Gitarren, wo steht, bitte nicht Stairway to Heaven, steht neben den Dirigierstaben, bitte nicht Beethovens neun.
Bitte nicht Beethovens fünfte, weil dann haben wir keinen Bock drauf.
Nein, haben wir keine Lust drauf.
Weil alle Musiker im Raum müssen dir folgen, wenn du dirigierst. Automatisch, super nervig, auch erst mal dieses am Pult zu stehen und den Spartan. Heißt es nicht Barton? Ich weiß es nicht genau. Melissa Barton? Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie die heißen, wie die in der Fachsprache ist. Ich meine, das heißt, ist das Barton. Aber wenn ich googles und Google sagt, sowas weißt du. Wenn ich Dirigent wäre, ich hätte wirklich so ein Halfter oder Holster oder Halfter an der Seite, wo die locker nochmal so ein kleiner Miniköcher, wo locker nochmal 20 Dirigierstäbe drinstecken und wo man einfach weiß, okay, der Mann hat Vorrat. So Legolas-mäßig, so ein Köcher. Aus dem Rücken, ja. Und einfach mitten im Höhepunkt der Sinfonie auch einfach rutscht mir der Stock aus der Hand und ich ziehe aus dem Köcher einfach direkt den nächsten. Das finde ich super. Ich muss kurz googeln, weil ich stell mir gerade selber vor, wie man das... Du bist verwirrt. Du verwechselst Bela Bartok, Barton Fink, du bist wirklich komplett lost gerade. Taktstab. Google meldet sich und sagt, pass auf, wir machen das, okay? Lass mich fahren, lass mich fahren. Setz dich auf den Beifahrersitz, lass mich fahren gerade. Stefan! So, jetzt geht's aber los, Google hat aber auch einen schlechten Teil. Jetzt hab ich hier geguckt, was Dirigierstab heißt, auf Englisch meine ich auch, jetzt klinge ich auf Englisch und dann sagt er mir Englisch,
dann zeigt er mir einen Artikel an über den Eintrag von Englisch. Nicht, wie kann, Beispiele, wie kann ich mein Englisch verbessern? Im Englischen wird vieles anders geschrieben. Wirklich? Das ist auch spannend, aber nicht meine Frage. Ist es auch egal. Ich meine, in der Serie Mozart in the Jungle entnommen zu haben, dass sie zum Dirigier-Taktstock, Dirigentenstab, was auch immer was anderes sage, ein Wort mit B. Barton. Barton, ne? Barton. Ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher, aber ist es nicht eher italienisch, diese Musiksprache, dass man italienische Begriffe verwendet? Genau. Der Maestro benutzt ... Du, ich weiß es nicht. Wir warten alle noch auf unsere Spezialfolge Antenne Alberich mit Christian Thielemann. Da können wir solche Fragen alle durchexerzieren. Das können wir dann endlich alle mal alle Dirigenten fragen, die uns allen so auf der Seele brennen, auf der Zunge ruhen, können wir dann endlich mal alle klären. Das wäre schön. Ich hätte gerne mal ein Interview mit einem Dirigenten, wo nicht die Frage gestellt wird, was machen sie eigentlich genau. Was ist eigentlich genau ihr Job? Ginge es auch ohne sie, ist so generell die erste Frage. Die haben ja die Noten. Ja, technisch gesehen ging es auch ohne mich, aber ich bin halt auch da. Und ich meine, fragen Sie auch einen Fussballtrainer, ging es auch ohne Sie? Natürlich kann die Mannschaft auch ohne Trainer spielen am Spieltag, aber halt schlechter. Und ich muss Leute auswechseln manchmal, aber halt schlechter. Gefällt mir auch so ein sehr aggressiver Dirigent. Das ist ja auch oft Quatsch, weil die sind ja meistens so sehr bei sich. Ich war jetzt am Wochenende in meiner Heimatstadt und habe mir das Weihnachtsoratorium gegeben. Schade, dass du dich das erste Mal richtig ausgesprochen hast. Du hattest dich so gefreut. Du gehst extra in ein Konzert. Warum? Um Leuten davon zu erzählen, wo du denkst, oh krass, der Stefan war im Weihnachtsoratorium, stehst vor dem Spiegel zu Hause und er... Ich habe es dreimal geübt. Und im Moment rutscht es dir aus dem Finger und der gesamte Credit, den du aufgebaut hast bei unseren Hörerinnen und Hörern, ist kaputt. Weil du warst vielleicht im Konzert, aber du kannst es nicht aussprechen. Das Ober-Oberatorium. Mann! Und dann im Moment dreimal vom Spiegel-Weihnachts-Oberatorium sagt, dann erscheint Bach hinter dir und schiebt dir seinen Baten in den Mund. Das ist ein ganz billiges Wichtelgeschenk, so eine Packung Rollo oder so, mit so einem, ja, sorry, mir ist nichts anderes eingefallen. Spot on Bach. Bach ist Franzose? Ja, okay. Und bevor man die Frage stellen kann, ist er schon wieder verschwunden? Und du guckst dich um und du siehst nur ein offenes Fenster und du denkst dir, Bach, Bach, Bach. Und du siehst Arnold Schweizernecker, der sagt, he'll be back. Und man denkt, what the fuck is happening? He'll be back, he'll be back Ja, auch Franzose. Und Bach streng genommen, guter Gag, Wunder der Weiner. Ja. Welche historische Figur hat die schlechtesten Weihnachtsgeschenke geschenkt? Jetzt überleg mal bitte gute 40 Minuten. Ja, ich überlege. Machen wir hier mal ganz einen kurzen Cut. Und jeder nimmt sich mal 40 Minuten, schreibt gerne Liste, welche historische Figur hat die schlechtesten Geschenke gegeben? Wo man sagt, geil, oh, du hast, krass, du hast Albert Einstein im Freundeskreis, cool, und du denkst dir, nee, so cool ist das nicht. Der war ja verkopft und halt immer with the heads in the clouds, wie der Italiener zu sagen pflegt, wo man dann auch sagt, der hat wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht viele Gedanken an Weihnachten verschwendet um seine Geliebten. Da kriegt man auch so eine aufgemachte Packung Rollo einfach. Ich weiß noch, ich habe einmal ein Wichtelgeschenk gemacht und das war eine Packung Rollo. Und seitdem ist diese Referenz... Bei mir ist also wirklich Publikum eins, diese Referenz kommt sehr, sehr gut an bei mir selber.
Niemand versteht das. Niemand kennt Rollo.
Ja, Rollo gibt es selten. Es sind so manche Sissigkeiten, die es selten gibt.
Es sind diese Karamellbrocken-Schokolade drum. Also Spot-on-Referenz wirklich auch. Das kennt man selten.
Referenzen müssen ... Ich bin ja eher der Schafschütze, was Referenz ... Hauptsache, ich lache selber. Hört den Podcast jemand? Ich mache das primär für mich selbst. Thomas Alvis Edison. Thomas Alvis Severus Alvis Edison hat meiner Meinung nach die schlechtesten Geschenke gemacht. Weil er die ganzen Materialien durchgehen musste für die Glühbirne oder was? Dann hatte er ganz viel Wolfram rumliegen, hat gesagt,, diesen ganzen Wolfram-Scheiss hier taugt nichts für die Glühbirne. Und dann sagt die Frau, ja verschenk das doch. Ach Quatsch, du kannst doch hier nicht Wismut verschenken. Klar, vor allem Wolfram hat einen Zweck zu erfüllen, Drecksglühbirne. Nichts anderes kann dieses was auch immer. Ja, tausendelang wartet es auf seinen Moment. Eisenzeit, Bronzezeit, Gold, Mürre wartet immer noch. Mürre wartet immer noch auf den Gronen. Hatte einmal, wenn man sich diese Google-Suchstatistik anguckt, Mürre einmal Riesenpeak, seitdem nichts mehr. Im Jahr Null. Ja, ironically, ziemlich genau im Jahr Null gab es kurz so einen kleinen Peak für Mürre, wo wirklich aber Hunderttausende sich das angeguckt haben. Und seitdem wirklich in so abgehalfterten Talkshows versucht eine Autorenkarriere zu machen, funktioniert nicht. Niemand will Myrre. Wohingegen Wolfram hatte seinen Moment. Hatte auch seinen Moment. In einem Jahr, was ich jetzt nicht so gut benennen könnte wie Myrre. War wahrscheinlich damals auch bei den beliebten Weihnachtsgeschenken, suchen ganz oben Myrre. war immer so Trendgeschenk. Aber Edison ist eine super Antwort.
Edison ist eine gute Antwort, weil er hat ja nicht mal,
er war ja kein kreativer Kerl, er hat ja nicht mal
das hinbekommen. Sorry, er hat die Glühbirne erfunden.
Hat er ja nicht. Du hast eine Serie über Kinder, die Drogen nehmen
geschrieben, da ist er natürlich noch
nicht an dem Kreativitäts-Olymp
angekommen, das ist klar.
Nee, sorry. Aber er hat halt
nur die Glühbirne erfunden. Hat er ja nicht.
Stefan Tietze sagt, Daumen nach unten. Kein Edison-Tipp, nein, nein, das ist natürlich, legst du mir jetzt wieder Überhilflichkeitschef an den Mund. Nein, stimmt nicht, der hat die Glühbirne wahrscheinlich nicht erfunden, sondern sie einfach nur rigoros abgeschrieben, weil der keine eigenen Ideen hat. Aber der musste doch die ganzen Drähte durchprobieren, habe ich gehört. In der Glühbirne ist ja so ein Draht, der, wenn Strom durchfließt, glüht. Aber welches Material hat der Draht? Und der hat hunderte verschiedene Materialien, Glas, Milch, Sahne, alle verschiedene Materialien. Aber sein Problem, er hat ja quasi abgeschrieben. Stefan, wir haben beide keine Ahnung. Wir diskutieren hier was immer. Ich erkläre es dir, wie es lief. Wir haben beide keine Ahnung. Ich erkläre es dir, wie es läuft. Null, wir wissen nichts. Doch, er ist in dieses Studio von diesem anderen gegangen. Den Namen weiß ich jetzt nicht. So, geht da jetzt hin. Tesla, sagen wir mal. Tesla, E-R hinten. Reinhard Tesla. Reinhard Tesla. So, dann geht er rein in sein Studio und hat seine Aufzeichnung, in sein Atelier, Studio-Atelier, und hat seine ganzen Aufzeichnungen geklaut.
Und er war schon ziemlich weit mit der Glühbirne.
Ihm fehlte nur noch das Material des Drades in der Mitte.
Genau.
Er nimmt alles mit, Thomas Albus, Severus, McGonagall, Addison,
nimmt alles mit, läuft in sein eigenes Atelier und baut es nach.
Was hat er gebaut? Der war auch reicher als der andere.
Weil er hat alle Material, können er schnell besorgen. Osram vielleicht. Genau, Osram. Oswald Osram. Oswald Osram. Und baut dann dieser Glühbirne nach. Und das einzig, was fehlt in der Mitte, dieses Draht. Und Osram weiß natürlich genau, was er dafür benutzt hätte. Er hätte es noch nicht aufgeschrieben. Nein, weiß er nicht. Das ist Quatsch jetzt. Das legst du Osram jetzt ins Grab. Nee, das kannst du nicht machen. Und Thomas Albus Edison hat keine Ahnung und probiert allen Scheiss aus, wo alle Physiker immer teilweise sagen würden, Unsinn, dass er überhaupt Zimt ausprobiert hat an dieser Stelle und dann irgendwann Glücksgriff Wolfram, weil er es eher überliegen hatte von letzten Weihnachten, weil ihm seine Freunde, die ihn nicht mochten, nur Wolfram geschenkt haben. Ja, die haben die Geschenke wieder zurückgegeben. Ja. Die haben wirklich am 2. Januar gesagt, du pass auf, wir geben dir die Geschenke wieder zurück. Wir geben dir Wolfram wieder zurück. Und er macht Wolfram, spannt da rein und zack, Glühbirne läuft und er sagt, je Patent, Patent, Patent, Patent, ich, ich, Addison, Addison, E-D-I-S-O-N-N-N. So, und dann hat er das Patent, und wir glauben, es hat Thomas Albus Addison geschrieben, erfunden, stimmt nicht. Und deswegen, glaube ich, wäre er auch sehr schlechter Schenker gewesen, weil er nicht mal das, wofür er bekannt ist, sich selbst ausgedacht hat. Also was hat er geschenkt? Nur Quatsch. Oder sehr gut, weil er sehr reich war und geliebt werden wollte von seinem Umfeld. Ja, vielleicht so Feinkostnüsschen oder sowas. So überzogene Nüsse mit unter verschiedenen Sachen. Überzogene Nuss. Die ist überzogen, ne? So ein bisschen. Das ist ja so ein bisschen. Also die ist komplett überzogen, ey, wirklich. Ich finde die auch, die sich einfallen lässt. Ja, was die sich einbildet, die ist komplett überzogen. Ja. Mürre. Ja, das leidige Thema Mürre, wirklich. Hört einfach auf, das zu wichteln, der Gag ist seit ziemlich genau 2021 Jahren durch, das funktioniert nicht mehr, haha, bei jedem Büro, Wichtel, Gruppen, Bildungs gibt's immer einen, haha, Harry aus aus der Buchhaltung, denkt es sei lustig, Mürre zu schenken und Bettina muss dann irgendwie das ganze Jahr gucken, was sie mit der fucking Mürre macht. Aber jetzt kommt es, ausgerechnet in diesem Jahr, das ist auch ein bisschen die Jahresrückblick Folge, ne? Ja. Ausgerechnet in diesem Jahr erlebt Mürre das grosse Revival, denn Mürre wurde zur Arzneipflanze des Jahres gewählt. Nein! Ja, jetzt, nach 2000 Jahren kam raus. Ich hab's euch doch gesagt! Und der eine der heiligen drei Könige so, ich hab's euch gesagt. Oder? Oder? Myrrhe! Ihr habt gesagt, das Quatsch, aber es ist eine gute Darmarznei. Ach, herrlich. Habt ihr Darm? Dann haut euch mal schön Mürre-Tee rein. Einfach Mürre reinballern. Der interdisziplinäre Studienkreis, Entwicklungsgeschichte der Arzneipflanzenkunde, hat die Stammpflanze und seine Bedeutung in der Medizingeschichte der weitreichenden wissenschaftlichen Erforschung und sein Potential als wirksame Darmarznei zur Arzneipflanze des Jahres 2021 gewählt. Das heisst, bei der Überlegung, was schenkt man dem Heiland, dem kleinen Christuskind, hat dieser König gesagt,
ja, mal so ein schönes Abführmittel. Warum nicht? Warum nicht?
Warum nicht? Renny räumt den Magen auf schön, du schenkst Rollo und ein anderer Typ schenkt, weiß ich nicht, Gold.
Und alle so, what the fuck?
Gold, Alter, wir haben gesagt fünf Denar, mehr nicht.
Aber vielleicht war es ja auch wenig Gold, wir wissen ja nicht, es wird nur überliefert, er schenkt Gold, aber nicht wie viel.
Es kann ja auch so irgendwie eine Silbe Blattgold gewesen sein, so ein kleines Ding, mit so einer Pinzette, dann wie so ein heißes Tuch, holt er das aus seiner Schatulle raus, so mit so einer Pinzette, so ein ganz
hauchdünnes Blattgold,
wo Maria sagt, danke, leg's auf den Tisch,
legst du den anderen Blattgolden.
Nichts damit tun, nichts,
gar nichts. Und als er das rausgut hat aus seiner
Schatulle, sah man in der Schatulle auch andere
Stücke. Ja, allerdings. Er hätte noch
mehr gehabt. Du, sorry, ich muss heute Abend
noch zu Buddha, ich muss halt noch
vorbei, wir haben heute einen vollen Tag. Wie lange sind die geblieben eigentlich in dem Stall? Wie lange sagt man, okay, Highland und so, aber ich bin schon ein Palast gewohnt und ich würde es dann auch packen ins Hotel, weil schon ein bisschen wenig Kalt hier, wenig Sterne. Kalt hier auch in der Krippe, ein Stern am Himmel. Ein Stern von fünf, das reicht mir nicht. Ich würde es dann langsam packen und die anderen beiden, ja gut. Gut, dann schließen wir uns an. Genau, dann würden wir auch dann direkt gehen. Kennen ja auch niemanden. Vielleicht können wir uns eine Kutsche zeigen. Die Hirten kennen die ja nicht. Niemand sprechen wahrscheinlich nicht dieselbe Sprache. Glaube ich auch nicht. Die drei Könige aus dem Morgenabend-Mittagsland, was auch immer. Mittagsparadies. Unterwegs, deswegen schwierige Situation, ja. Ja genau, dann sind sie, glaube ich, nach Hause gegangen, relativ schnell wieder. Es ist die Frage, wie lange es gesellschaftlich akzeptiert, mindestens zu bleiben auf der Geburtsfeier des Heilands, des Messias Jesu. Superschwierig, superschwierig. Aber sie sind gekommen und sind in die Bibel aufgenommen worden. Also da zeigt sich, es lohnt sich, Geschenke zu machen, es lohnt sich zu kommen. Und liegen im Kölner Dom. Leute werden sich daran erinnern. Liegen im Kölner Dom begraben. Die Gebeine der Heiligen Reichskönige sind ja im Dom zu Köln begraben. Wohingegen der Heilige Vierte König, der zu Hause geblieben ist und eine Karte geschickt hat, nichts. Wird nicht erwähnt, Gebeine, wer weiß, irgendwo in der Wüste vergraben. Interessiert niemand. Aber zu zu seiner Verteidigung, er hatte einen mega Abend. Er hat nicht gefroren, keine socially awkward Smalltalks, er war einfach zu Hause, vorm Fernseher und hatte eine gute Zeit. Und er hat so viel Rollo genascht, wie er wollte, weil er hatte die ganze Packung da. Er hat sich die dreimonatige Reise gespart, alles weil er einen Abend abgesagt hat. Wir können alle der vierte König sein, gut, dann liegen wir am Ende nicht im Kölner Dom, sondern einfach zu Hause, wo wir herkommen. Ja, schon eingewickelt, in seiner Lieblingsdecke, ist auch nett. In seinem Däckchen. Eigentlich ist der der Held der ganzen Geschichte, der der zu Hause geblieben ist. Der vierte fucking König. Einfach so ein Appendix in der Bibel, einfach alle, die zu Hause geblieben sind, nochmal vielen Dank an alle, die eine Karte geschickt haben, aber nicht gekommen sind. Und dann so die Könige, Kaiser, Sultane aus der ganzen Welt, die gesagt haben, ja, gehen doch da extra hin. Was hatten Sie denn vor, Herr Vierter König, was hatten Sie denn vor am 24. Du, ich wollte noch mal, weil da läuft ja auch echt gute Sachen in der Feuerstelle, muss man sagen. Da sind ja echt tolle, tolle Proportagen und so. Manche sagen, sie hätten Bock einfach. Nein, nee, klar, mir ist das super wichtig, als ich vom Stern gehört habe, dachte ich mir, da muss ich hin. Aber ich wäre halt auch nicht mehr rechtzeitig gekommen. Ich wohne so weit weg und die Kamele, boah, und dann kommst du dann zwei Wochen später, niemand ist mehr da, Maria räumt immer noch den Scheiss auf, irgendwie den Vorhang, muss sie komplett waschen, irgendwie war einer, der Hirten sich übergeben hat, so. Das ist dann auch nicht die Situation, wo man auftauchen will mit seinen Geschenken. Deswegen bleibe ich zu Hause. Jetzt habe ich mal in dem Umfeld recherchiert und herausgefunden, dass sie auch vielen anderen so Baby-Showers ferngeblieben sind. Manche sagen, dass sie ein bisschen antisozial sind. Johannes der Täufer, da war ich da. Ja, nee. Nee, da waren sie auch nicht. Wie hieß der Kleine? Waren sie nicht. Dieser eine Typ da, wie war der denn nochmal? Schreck. Schreck? Ja, Schreck war ich dabei. Da waren sie nicht. Judas, irgendwie sowas. Judas war ich dabei, der hat ganz schlicht, ganz nette, schlichte Einfamilienhaus, nicht diese Stallnummer. Der war da, ich habe mir ein Stück Kuchen genommen, da bin ich gegangen. War nett, war nett. Da war ich. Sie sind ein antisemitisches Arschloch für den König. Darf ich Sie dafür enthaupten? Kaspar Melchior, Balthasar und wie ist Ihr Name? Walter. Dennis. Balthasar. Moment, du heisst Walther-Sahr? Ich bin Balthasar.
Ja und? Dennis. Walther-Sar.
Wie, Moment, du heisst Walther-Sar? Ich bin Walther-Sar. Ja und? Wie soll das denn über die Tür gehen? Was? Ich hatte eine Idee, wir schreiben mit Kreide unsere Initialen über die Tür. Wie soll das denn? Ja, das ist doch geil oder nicht? War das der erste Anfang von Streetart eigentlich?
Ist das so ein bisschen Graffiti, ist ein Tag.
Ja.
C plus M plus B gleich her. Ist doch geil oder nicht? War das das erste Anfang von Streetart eigentlich? Ist das so ein bisschen Graffiti, ist ein Tag.
C plus M plus B gleich Herz.
Da hast du doch jetzt mal einen Tweet, oder?
So ein Foto von dieser Kreideinschrift.
Ist das ein echter Sankt Banksy oder so?
Leute, er haut ihn raus!
Ja, er haut ihn raus!
Aber dann müssen die erst mal zu mir kommen.
Das wäre auch die Horrorvorstellung, die Tür aufzumachen und sind da sing singende Kinder. Immer versteckt, immer versteckt, wenn die kamen. Aber schon erst Tür aufgemacht, dann versteckt. Falsche Reihenfolge. Tür auf, irgendwie Geldschein raus und versteckt. Nee. Wahrscheinlich wissen wir gar nicht viele, wovon wir reden. Ich glaube, es ist eher ein katholischer Brauch. Du bist ja auch im tiefsten Bayern aufgewachsen, da ist man dann schon eher Katholik, oder?
Ja, ich auch. Im tiefsten Westen, wobei das ist egal. Mittlerweile glaube ich, hast du über evangelisch und katholisch gemischt.
Und so, aber ich bin da auch mit aufgewachsen und es ist schon auch einiges anders gewesen.
Also bei mir, meine ganzen evangelischen Kollegen, Buddies hatten alle ein bisschen lockere Zeit. Also da hat sich Luther bis zum Ende hin durchgesetzt, ein bisschen locker vom Hocker, war der Luther. Und zwar These 72. Seid mal alle ein bisschen locker, macht euch mal locker. Ich bin jetzt bei These 28, das ist auch eine krumme Zahl, oder? Nee, mach 100. Fuck, ich krieg die nicht voll. Ich krieg die nicht voll. Ich krieg die nicht voll. Du kannst ja nicht 30 Thesen machen, das ist doch Quatsch. Guck mal, lateinisch, wie sieht das aus? V, V, V? Ne, x, x, sorry, x, x, x. Das ist doch Quatsch. Kurz Blackout. Ja, dann mach doch mal ein bisschen, dann mach doch mal, ist doch auch egal, also die wenigsten lesen ja eh bis 28, die wenigsten können überhaupt gerade lesen. Dann mach doch mal irgendwie. Ich meine, These 12 wird euch umhauen. So, wenn das die Überschrift ist, lesen die Leute noch bis 12 und dann eh nicht mehr weiter. Ja, genau, das glaube ich auch nicht. Gut, dann mach ich noch fünf Thesen oder so. Ja, mach mal fünf Thesen. Ich habe kaum Thesen. Ich habe wirklich kaum noch Thesen. Hat jemand noch eine These übrig? Das ist genau wie Martin Luther. Ich kann das vielleicht ein Tweet, muss man jetzt noch reingießen, aber das kennt man ja das Gefühl, wenn man sagt, wenn man einen Satz anfängt wie das aus drei Gründen Quatsch oder so was. Genau. Oder da könnte ich dir jetzt hundert Gründe nennen. Ja, mach mal. Und man fällt nur neun neunzeig. Also wieso ist das Unsinn? Du hast erstens, und dann hast du den offensichtlichen Grund, und hast dann gemerkt, shit, ich habe mit erstens angefangen, es muss mindestens noch ein zweites folgen, ich habe immer nur einen Grund gehabt, diese Momente, wo man sich kurz aus dem Fenster lehnt, und so war Martin Luther, glaube ich, auch. Wie hart muss Martin Luther über eine hundertste These nachgedacht haben, bevor er gesagt hat, Faket 99? Ich finde es stark. Warum macht man nicht die 100 voll? Warum sagt man nicht einfach, du kriegst dann noch irgendeine These, du machst dann einfach, ja, Kuchengabeln ist überbewertet, irgendwas Kleines, was Knackiges am Ende. Du kannst ja auch nie beschreiben. Nee, ich find das super. Nee, aber 99. Weil das klingt so, als ob er, bei jeder hat das ernst gemeint. Das stört mich aber an zehn Punkte Plänen, stört mich am meisten, dass, warum kommt ihr auf eine gerade Zahl? Ja, richtig. Ihr habt einen sieben Punkte Plan und die drei habt ihr euch ausgedacht, damit es besser klingt. Und ich finde es bei ihm so geil, bei 99 denkt man so, ha, ihm war es wirklich mit allen 99 Punkten ernst, weil entweder hätte er nach 50 aufgehört oder die 100 voll gemacht. Nach 98. 99, das ist so wie 101 Dalmatiner so. Ha, ha, ha. Ein Gag. Ein Gag. Ja, deswegen waren die ja so locker, die Evangelin, die Protestanten, Freunde. Vielleicht gab es da auch Konkurrenten, wir kennen ja heute nur Martin Luther, vielleicht gab es da auch viele andere Protestanten oder Reformatoren, die gesagt haben, lass uns das mal anders machen. Und die hatten dann halt irgendwie hundert Thesen und Luther hat gesagt, tja, wie so ein 99-Cent-Shop, bei mir müsst ihr nur 99 Thesen lernen. war das wirklich hart umkämpft. Könnte man auch eine tolle Serie drüber schreiben, aber du machst ja nichts mehr. Ich mache nichts mehr. Du machst ja gar nichts mehr. Nächstes Jahr habe ich ja noch. Ich habe noch ein Jahr und dann wurde vergessen, was ich vorher gemacht habe. Und dann ist das Fenster zu. Ich habe große Angst vor schliessenden Fenstern. Ja? Ich habe das Gefühl, wenn man ein Fenster auffällt, muss man durchsteigen. Ja? Ich habe Angst, dass das Fenster sich schliesst. Ich habe zum Beispiel neulich war ich im Restaurant am Nebentisch, haben Leute ein Gericht gehabt, wo ich echt gerne wissen wollte, was es ist. Und da bin ich meiner Begleitung extrem auf die Nerven gegangen, weil ich der ganze Zeit dachte, ich traue mich nicht zu fragen, aber ich will gerne fragen, was war, was war, was war. Und ich habe dann gemerkt, wie das Fen fenster in dem es socially acceptable wäre noch zu
fragen was das da war zugeht weil irgendwann war das essen weg irgendwann haben die nachspeisen bekommen also aufgegessen es wurde auf von den beiden aufgessen und dann wurde abgeräumt der wurden abgeräumt ich kann jetzt noch fragen eigentlich wäre es ein guter zeitpunkt dann kam aber die nachspeise schon und dann kam jemand die rechnung und dann dachte ich mir das wenn Das Fenster ist closed, es ist verrammelt.
Das Fenster ist zu, die Rollosise schon. Und dann kam irgendwann die Rechnung. Und dann dachte ich mir, das Fenster ist
closed, es ist verrammelt.
Das Fenster ist zu, die Rollos sind runter.
Die Rollos sind
runter und es ist wie so ein Zombiefilm
noch so eine große Holzplanke
dagegen gemacht worden. Und dann
habe ich noch gefragt. Und man hat
gemerkt, an der Frage, dass das Fenster
closed war, weil beide so
das letzte Essen? Nein, das, nein, das davor. Der Hauptgang. Das war einfach der letztmögliche Zeitpunkt. Die beiden sitzen schon im Auto, du rennst über den Parkplatz, klopfst an die Scheibe, Entschuldigung, wie hieß es das erste Set? Das war ein Pinocchio-Becher. Okay, danke, danke. Alles klar. muss man warten, bis Leute, so ein Brief, in zehn Jahren kommt ein Brief an. Genau, ja. Ja, hallo zusammen. Ich habe lange gebraucht, ihre Adresse zu finden. Fragen Sie nicht wie, einige, einige Wesolianer mussten doch besterben, dass sie ihre Adresse herausgefunden haben. Kleiner Callback zu Rogue One. aber ich habe den namen schlechter Callback, weil mir auch diese Rasse nicht mehr einfiel, die dann diese Pläne besorgt hat. Ich dachte, Venezuela? Venezuelaner. Habe ich irgendwo, weil ich bin tagesaktuell, glaube ich, eher schwach auf der Brust. Gibt es einen aktuellen Skandal um Venezuela, wo irgendwas passiert ist? Was spielt die an? Ich habe mir vor, wenn in Star Wars so, außerdem nichts plötzlich, immer nur die Wookies und die Twi'leks und so, und dann plötzlich die Venezuelaner, viele Venezuelaner mussten sterben für die Pläne. Man denkt so als Kinobesucher, Moment. Was? Es gibt die Erde nicht, aber Venezuela gibt's. Ja, das gibt's. Auf einem anderen Planeten. Es sieht im Dagobah-System, es sieht exakt genauso aus. Es spricht noch Spanisch, fliessend Spanisch, ola ola. Ja, und dann haben die mir das gesagt und das war sehr antiklimatisch, ich wollte aber wissen, was es war und habe aber noch mal gemerkt, wie wichtig es ist, dass man auf offene und zu Fenster jeweils achtet. Wow, das ist wirklich für deine Begleitung wahrscheinlich interessant. Nicht nur schaust du die ganze Zeit auf den Nachbartisch rüber, schaust du das Essen der anderen an, sondern das Einzige, was dich interessiert, ist, wie heißt dieses Essen? Willst du denn zumindest den Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauern die Möglichkeit geben, den Fehler zu vermeiden und zu sagen, was es war? Nee, es würde auch jetzt zu lang führen. Aber ist es dir A, zu peinlich, dass du so einen Aufstand um Wiener Schnitzel gemacht hast, oder b würde das verraten, dass du in zu fancy Restaurants unterwegs bist, dass du nicht mehr als Naber und Kiez-Legende Stefan T. gilt?
Beides grosses nein. Ich war ganz normal in das Restaurant, es gab nur, ich habe da so ein Menü gehabt und ich wollte gerne wissen, ob die das gleiche Menü hatten.
Weil die ganz, es war das Überraschungsmenü und meine These war den ganzen Abend schon, ha gut, weil ich habe mich erst gefreut, wenn man ein bisschen drumprobieren kann und man auf Dinge gestossen wird, die man wahrscheinlich nicht essen würde vielleicht. Und weil ich immer der Wiener Schnitzel-Typ bin, hab ich dann das Überraschungsmenü gewählt, dachte aber die ganze Zeit, bei jedem Gang, der kam, so, waren jetzt auch nicht fancy viele Gänge, von daher nein, aber ich dachte bei jedem Gang, der kam so, aber das ist jetzt so einfach der Rest-Ding, weil warum Überraschungsmenü? Das ist jetzt ja nicht kein ausgewähltes Menü, wahrscheinlich einfach nur, was ihr gerade überhabt. Und du wolltest wissen, ob der andere Tisch, sozusagen, ob bei jedem Gang neu gewürfelt wird, oder ob das Überraschungsmenü am Anfang des Abends feststeht und jeder dieses Überraschungsmenü bekommt. Genau. Ich wollte wissen, werden wir hier gerade nach Strich und Faden verarscht? Oder kriegen wir das, was runtergefallen ist, was nicht mehr serviert werden kann, das kriegst du als Überraschung. Weil ich dachte, das ist ja bestimmt ausgewählt zumindest, dass die Gänge irgendwie aufeinander passen, aber die am Nebentisch sah so aus für mich, als ob die auch das Überraschungsmenü hätten, aber die haben immer andere Sachen bekommen und die sahen teilweise geiler aus. Und dann sind bei mir Alarmglocken angegangen, weil ich dachte, die mögen die lieber so unerträglich sein mit dir im Restaurant sitzen. Ich habe dann gedacht, das ist furchtbar. Nee, ich fand es einfach spannend, weil was geht hier gerade vor sich? Weil die haben auch das Überraschungsmenü. Werde ich betrogen gerade? So, und das ganze Ausholen wollte ich hier sparen. Aber ich wollte einfach wissen, ob die das Überraschungsmenü hatten. Da habe ich am Ende, als das Fenster schon zu war, bin ich zum Parkplatz gelaufen und habe gesagt, du, du, du, du, du, das Überraschungsmenü und bei er so, äh, ja, und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, aber ihr habt doch ganz andere Sachen gehabt als wir. Ja, das war eine Überraschung. Dann meinte er, nee, weil sie sehr viele Allergien haben und dann, boah, genial, aber das kannst du auch nicht machen, ich hätte gerne einmal das Überraschungsmenü, aber bitte nicht x, y, z, sondern es ist auch kein Überraschungsmenü mehr. Ja, doch. Mancher muss ein Überraschungsmenü auch im Krankenhaus enden, das gehört dazu, das ist Teil der Überraschung. Das ist auch gesagt. Aber er hat, glaube ich, gesagt, er steht nicht so auf, weiß ich nicht, Sardellen oder sowas. Und ehrlich gesagt hätte ich es auch lieber sagen sollen, weil dann wären mir viele Sardellengerichte erspart geblieben. Da würde ich jemanden aus dem Restaurant schmeißen und mir dann sagen, ich hätte gerne das Überraschungsmenü, aber bitte keine Sardellen. Ja, dann nehme ich das Überraschungsmenü, du willst offensichtlich nicht überrascht werden. Aber wenn das ein Problem ist, wie viele Sardellen hattet ihr vor, reinzumachen in mein Überraschungsmenü, wenn ihr mich jetzt rausschmeißt, weil ich da keine Sardellen in meinem Überraschungsmenü bin? Ja, es ist Sardellen, jeder Gang ist Sardellen. So ist es nun mal, es ist keine grosse Überraschung mehr nach der Vorspeise, aber das ist halt, ja.
Die Vorspeise, was Sardellen auf Sardellen mag. Sardellensauce und ja, dann können wir es halt nicht machen, können wir euch halt nicht überraschen. Aber ich glaube, das ist eh gut. Ich glaube ja, das Angebot wird immer größer, so viele Serien, Filme, der Mensch kann sich gar nicht mehr entscheiden. Ich glaube, der Zufall, die Überraschung wird eine grössere Rolle spielen. Zum Beispiel, ich bin immer gerne ins Kino gegangen in die Sneak Peek, wo du nicht wusstest, welchen Film du anschaust. Neuer Film, wusstest nicht, was es ist und es hat richtig Spaß gemacht, weil du wusstest nicht, was passiert, du konntest dich auf den Abend nicht vorbereiten, du hattest dich nie geärgert, dass du irgendwie die... Entschuldigung, sie konnten dich nicht auf den Abend vorbereiten, das heißt, bei jedem anderen Kinogang wird sich erstmal exzessiv auf den Kinogang vorbereitet. Ja, natürlich, klar, wenn du in eine Komödie gehst, gehst du mit einem anderen Mindset rein, als wenn
du jetzt irgend so ein Krankheitsdrama, irgendwie
sozialer Brennpunktdrama
reingehst. Da geht man mit einer anderen Stimmung rein.
Mit einem anderen Shirt.
Da wird in der Werbung nicht lauthalslos gepustet,
wenn man einfach weiß, jetzt kommt hier
einfach drei Stunden, wir sind
aus unserer Wohnung geworfen worden,
Drama. Deswegen wusste man nicht, wie man reingeht. Die Crowd war immer anders, es war immer so, man wusste nicht, worauf man sich einlässt. Und deswegen würde ich euch empfehlen, viele leiden wahrscheinlich unter der noch nicht benannten Krankheit, dass ich kann mich nicht entscheiden und mache gar nichts. Sind alle Sneak Peaks, alle Zuschauer in dem Raum wissen nicht, was läuft. Richtig? Oder weil ich ja auch hier hätte ich wieder die Angst, dass man wieder denkt, also ich hätte wieder gedacht, fuck, jetzt werde ich in das eine Kino, was zu wenig Karten verkauft hat, gesteckt. Also, das Kino weiß, die Sneak Peek ist heute die Schlümpfe und schickt in das Kino alle, die Sneak Peek wollen, aber auch alle, die Schlümpfe sehen wollen. Alle die Schlümpfe, die sitzen schon drin. Genau. So, und die warten, die fragen sich auch, warum geht der Film drei Stunden nicht los, weil die halt den Saal auffüllen mit Sneak Previews. Okay, verstehe. Nee, so war es nicht. Woher weißt du das? Weil du aufgestanden bist und gefragt hast, Leute, wisst ihr alle nicht? Wenn wir uns alle gefreut haben, als wir gecheckt haben, was es für ein Film ist. Was war es für ein Film? Prison Break. Nee, ähm ...
Irgendwas mit Prison, mit Arnold Schwarzenegger und Sylvester Stallone.
Und dann nächste Woche denk ich mir, okay, jetzt wieder Sneak Peek.
Es war wieder Prison Break.
Es war wieder der gleiche Film.
Ich dachte, vielleicht ist das Konzept nicht so ganz ideal.
Meine große Angst bei diesen Überraschungen ist es halt immer, dass sie mich ausnutzen, mit meinem Wille überrascht zu werden. Das dachte ich sowohl bei dem Überraschungsmenü als auch bei dem Sneak Preview, dass ich den Schund bekomme, den letzten Schund. Ich habe James Bond gesehen und ich sag mal so, der der grösste Feind, was in meiner Filmkritik 80 Prozent würde einnehmen, die voll Idioten, die hinter mir saßen, nämlich eine Familie mit Kindern und einerseits dachte ich mir während der Werbung, denkst du dir immer so, du gehst ins Kino und denkst dir, bitte nicht bei den Kindern, bitte nicht bei den Kindern, bitte nicht bei den Kindern und du gehst das Alphabet hoch, die, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, und das ist direkt vor den Fakten.
Wo man sagen muss, in gewisser Weise ist jeder Film Sneak Peek.
Also, es ist ein bisschen Überraschung, was gerade passiert, wo man sitzt.
Auf der Ebene schon.
Und dann, aber während der Werbung und so hat die Mutter immer schon so psch psch zu den Kindern gemacht.
Wo ich mir dachte, geil, cool, da hat jemand, da weiß jemand, worum es geht.
Während des Films aber hat sowohl die Kinder als auch die Mutter konstant durchgeredet, die Mutter... Hat die übertragend, sie wollte die Werbung gucken, offensichtlich. Anscheinend, das war ihr wichtig. Was, was, was kommt der jetzt? Moment, Moment, Moment, aktiviert was? Aktiviert was? Ich hab's nicht mitbekommen. Und die Mutter hat während des Films gleichzeitig immer wieder psscht psscht gesagt, selber aber selber geredet die ganze Zeit, also ich weiß nicht, was das für eine Erziehungsmethode ist, den Kindern zu sagen, sie soll nicht reden und die Kinder dann Fragen zu stellen, wie, wer ist das jetzt, was ist der, ey und ich war außer mir, außer mir, Bei allem, das ist immer diese merkwürdige Art, Filme zu schauen, wo man denkt, weil da kommt halt dann irgend so wird irgendjemand erschossen und der Mörder trägt eine Maske. Und dann fragt sie, wer ist das jetzt? Und ich denke, Leute, als ob das jemand wüsste, der trägt eine Maske. Die Idee ist, dass man nicht weiss, wer das ist. Ein Film funktioniert durch Spannung, nicht alle Fragen sind beantwortet, als ob ihre Kinder jetzt sagen, ja, das ist der Walter Grösselich, als ob die das wüssten. Jesus. Oh Gott, ey, ich kann mich so aufregen. Vor allem die meisten Fragen, das weiß ich immer alles nicht. Also ich weiß auch oft nicht, will der Film jetzt, dass ich das schon weiß oder nicht weiß oder was auch immer. Plot, ich bin eh so langsam im Kopf, dass die meisten Fragen, die ich mir während eines Films stelle,, sind nicht plot related. Die meisten Fragen, die ich mir stelle, ist, wenn es irgendwie auf Deutsch sein musste, weil Köln keine fucking Kinos im OV hat, frage ich mich, wo erkenne ich diese Synchronstimme? Ja. Wie wäre der Gag auf Englisch gelaudet? Wie wäre der Gag offensichtlich nicht funktioniert? Stimmt, da habe ich noch ganz viele andere Sachen. Und wenn man das auf Englisch schafft zu gucken in Köln, dann sind es Fragen wie, woher kenne ich den Schauspieler nochmal? Fuck, es war irgendeine Serie, da habe ich noch neulich gegeben. Ah, White Lotus, sowas. Und aber nicht plot-related, selten plot-related. Und danach hatte ich sehr viele Fragen. Da habe ich meinen größten James-Bond-Fan-Kumpel gefragt, der mir dann eine zehn Minuten Sprachnachricht aufnehmen musste, mit warum. Und die meisten sagen, ist er James-Bond-mässig, der war einfach böse, sowas reicht mir auch nicht so richtig. Ich habe bis zum Ende nicht verstanden, was Rami Maddox Story war. Keine Ahnung. Ich habe verstanden, dass der alle vergiften will, aber wen er damit umbringen will, keine Ahnung, nicht verstanden, ist mir aber auch nicht so wichtig. Ich muss nicht alles verstehen. Und manchmal sind halt auch Fragen offen. Also, wir wollen jetzt auch nicht spoilern, aber Spoiler Alert geht nicht mit euren Kindern rein. Ja, bei dem Weihnachtsoratorium war auch ein Baby dabei. In dieser Kirche hat man so diesen, aber ich dachte mir irgendwann so, und ich freue mich lustig, ich bin dann da hingegangen, es war ganz geil, weil ich kannte halt die meisten Leute, die da vorne musiziert haben, weil ich mit denen auch damals immer gesungen habe, weil das war meine Musicalgruppe damals, Weil viele von denen sind in den Chören und so und waren dann da am Start, auch mein alter Lateinlehrer war im Chor und das war fantastisch für mich und ich fand es irgendwie geil auch zu sehen, wie die aufs Kind reagieren, ehrlich gesagt, weil da war halt dieses eine Baby mit in dieser Kirche und dann angefangen plötzlich rumzukrakehlen und alle waren auch genervt, weil die haben dann einmal in diesem Jahr füllen die halt dieses Weihnachtsoratorium von Bach auf und so und alle kommen zusammen und gucken sich das an und es ist irgendwie schön, aber da ist ja dieses Baby dabei, was ab Minute eins klar ist und ab Minute eins stellt man sich darauf ein, dass der Abend für den Arsch wird und ich meine sorry, aber wie schwer ist es denn eine Technologie zu entwickeln, ich meine Stichwort Noise Cancelling, so eine Art Helm, so eine Art Glocke, dem Kind aufzusetzen, ich will nicht, dass es erstickt, da sind wir einig, also ab einem gewissen Punkt will ich schon, dass es erstickt, aber angenommen, ich wäre jetzt Teil des Elternteams, Beirat, dass man sagt, ich will nicht, dass mein Kind erstickt, unbedingt, aber es soll leicht sein, wie schwer ist es, so einen Helm zu entwickeln, wenn man ein Kind aufsetzt, wo einfach der Schall aufgefangen wird, aber die Luft durchkommt? Ist das so schwer?
Ja, genau. So eine Glaskuppel auf den Babys und du siehst so schreien, rote, geschwollene Gesichter von den Tränen und ein bisschen beschlagen auch, diese Glaskuppel, weil so viele Tränen fließen, es regnet auch ein bisschen drin und du hast nichts. Ja, ich meine vor allem, das ist ja für die Eltern am nervigsten. Ist das denn so schwer? Gibt es das denn einfach so? So Helme oder sowas in der Richtung? Oder halt so eine Art, halt das Gegenteil von einer Trompetenheit, so was, was man so vor den Mund macht, so eine Art Silencer, so eine Art Schalldämpfer. Im Prinzip Schnuller die Idee. Schnuller ist ja ein Silencer. Schnuller der Film. Ja, ich weiß nicht, also guckt mal, falls ihr da irgendwie arbeitet bei Bose oder irgendwo so oder Rode
oder Sonos oder was auch immer, dass ihr
da mal so Helme entwickelt, bitte.
Bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte. Das wäre mein Wunsch
an euch für das nächste Jahr, toi, toi, toi.
Das fände ich richtig geil. Guckt mal, vielleicht ist Wolfram
ja eine Idee. Oder ist es moralisch
verwerflich, wie kriegt es sehr böse Nachrichten, weil
ein normal
Aspekt der Menschheit vergessen wird, dass man auch hören sollte, wenn Kinder schreien, weil es ihnen dann nicht gut geht, sowas. Naja, ich sage nicht, dass die Kinder den Helm konstant aufhaben sollen, aber wenn die Eltern schon gecheckt haben, aha, da wird geschrien, würde aber trotzdem gern schlafen, Helm auf. Es kann natürlich sein, es kann natürlich sein, dass die Eltern dann faul werden und den Helm einfach konstant auf dem Kind lassen. Und kann man dann so das Kind irgendwann nicht mehr ohne Helm leben.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, natürlich, aber du musst ja alles.
Weißt du mit der Black-Mirror-Folge.
Ja, aber du musst ja alles verantwortungsvoll einsetzen so. Das ist ja auch, du kannst ja auch nicht sagen.
Ich meine, es gibt ja auch verschiedene Sachen.
Ich finde auch nicht schlecht, wenn man dann so die Sauerstoffzufuhr so regulieren kann.
Jetzt nicht null oder hundert, aber sagen wir mal so.
Nee, null kann man nicht. Nee, aber so sechzig, wenn man dann so ein bisschen schläfrig wird. Ja, ja. Und dann schlafen die und dann wieder hundert auf. Ja, ja, ja, ja. Nee, alles gute Ideen. Wir überlegen uns das mal, weil das kann halt so hunderten Skandalen. So müde, lassen Sie mich los, warum fassen Sie das? Nein, dass man so ein bisschen müde wird. Ey, das ist ja mal eine Höhle der Löwenfolge, oder wo man einfach sagt, so der Helm. Und ja, Helm ist vielleicht falsch, aber vielleicht so eine Art Hologramm oder so, dass das Kind zu Hause bleibt. Ey, keine Ahnung, da müssen wir mal gucken, aber ich glaube, das ist eine Technologie, die könnte sich durchsetzen. Ey, so eine Glasglocke, den einfach aufzusetzen, finde ich ja super. Ich glaube, eh das ist die Zukunft. So eine Schnarchmaske. Das ist doch eh die Zukunft. Du wirst doch irgendwann nicht mehr ein Laptop mit dir rumtragen, sondern einfach so eine Brille aufhaben. Und irgendwann hast du halt einfach einen kompletten Helm auf, wo einfach alles Monitore drin sind, Kopfhörer, Display, alles angezeigt, du siehst die Welt um dich herum, schallisoliert, wunderbar, kannst keine Krankheiten mehr kriegen, alles wird Luft gefiltert, alles perfekt und alle haben so Helme auf, wo du dann die ganze Zeit an andere Leute stößt. Das ist die Werbung. Wie so ein Billardtisch. Ich dachte, willst du mir das verkaufen, wenn du stossst gegen andere Leute? Ja, weil die Helme halt auch recht voluminös sind. Und du dotzt halt ständig gegen andere, gerade wenn es eng wird, ist das unangenehm. Ja. Dann stösst man, und das Problem ist halt, es ist halt wie so ein, also alles wird zum Billardtisch. Eine U-Bahn-Fahrt ist ein Billard-Abend, weil alle diese Kugeln haben und halt alle dann so Einfallswinkel ist gleich Ausfallswinkel halt durch die Gegend U U-Bahn dotzen und irgendwann kannst du da auch nichts mehr dagegen machen.
Neulich kam jemand, habe ich schon mal erzählt, ein Mann in die U-Bahn, das fand ich faszinierend, der lief rein und war so sehr wütend, als er in die U-Bahn kam und hat erstmal alle Fenster aufgerissen. und ich fand das
so geil, weil
öffentliches Verkehrsmittel, das gehört
irgendwie uns allen, dachte ich
und er war der einzige, der es so benutzt, als wäre es wirklich seins. Er war einfach ein ganz normaler Beifahrer. Er lief rein und lief dann zu allen Fenstern und hat erstmal alle Fenster aufgemacht. Ich fand das so geil. Das ist schon gut. Weil ihm, hab mal diese Form von Selbstbewusstsein, dass dir die Stadt so sehr gehört, dass du einmal jetzt die U-Bahn-Station, die Fenster bestimmst. Ja. Fand ich geil. Weil ich dachte mir natürlich, das ist ja irgendwie, so eine Stadt ist eine große WG. Wir leben irgendwie so zusammen hier drin. Und es ist irgendwie unser Ding und es braucht halt mal einen, der die Fenster aufmacht. Ja, absolut. Es ist eh unsere Stadt und das habe ich auch neulich gedacht, als dann so so ein Strassenreinigungsfahrzeug so bei mir dann auch die Straße sauber gemacht hat, da dachte ich mir, danke. Das ist wie so ein WG-Mitbewohner, der die jetzt sauber macht, damit ich es wieder gemütlich habe. Ja. Und Leute machen das einfach und ich fand das so faszinierend, dass diese Stadt funktioniert.
Aber es ist irgendwie
unsere Stadt und da machten Leute die sauber.
Der Putzplan ist ...
Ich glaube, gäbe es einen Putzplan
für jeder Bürger Kölns,
muss einmal in seinem Leben, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Bürger
hat Köln, sondern eine Million,
das jetzt durch 365
ist mehr als genug,
so dass jeder einmal putzen muss. Und dass du einfach sagst, jeder muss mit diesem Putzautomat fahren, würde ich freiwillig machen, wenn ich so Dury Duty angerufen werde, so hier nächsten Donnerstag fährst du mit dem Müllsammelwagen, mit dieser Borstenmaschine, mit Borsti, und ich denke mir, ja sofort, Alter, geil, ein Tag mit der Borstenmaschine. Sie haben keine Fahrstunde vorher, Sie müssen das recht intuitiv lernen. Ja, klar, kein Problem. Ich habe Führerschein, ich habe verschiedene Wägen in meinem Leben probiert. Alles klar. Und ich bürste einfach alles weg, oder? Alles wird weggebürstet. Geil, mach ich das eigentlich gut, dass mein erster Tag als Telefonnist. In meiner Weise mache ich etwas ganz anderes. Aber dann bin ich dran mit dem Telefonieren. Nee, Sie machen das richtig gut. Cool, Sie machen das richtig gut. Mega, danke. Ich würde das einmal schön durch die Stadt borsten. Ich hätte auch Bock darauf, ich glaube, ich wäre der schlechteren. Aber macht der Borstenfahrer jeden Tag den Borstenmann oder rotieren die auch durch? Und saugt der oder schiebt der nur Dinge von A nach B? Ich glaube, der borstet nur nach rechts. Was ich auch nicht verstehe, Laubgebläse, habe ich nicht verstanden. Wo führt das denn hin? Wo führt das langfristig hin? Ja, man bläst das Problem nur beiseite. Nee, man verschiebt das Problem von nach B. Ich glaube, die Idee ist, dass dann schon am Ende steht der Sack. Am Ende hast du schon so eine Art Laubsack, in dem dann letzten Endes, ganz, ganz am Ende dieses langen, langen, komplexen Laubprozesses. Des langen, lauten und stinkenden Prozesses. Also am Anfang steht Photosynthese, dann erst mal Herbst, dann wird das Grünstoff zurückgezogen in den Baumstamm, dann fallen die runter, dann wird das Blatt geblasen auf einen Berg, da können dann entweder Igel drin wohnen oder nicht. Müssen aber nicht. Muss nicht sein? Müssen. Option. Die für Igel ist eine Option. Für die Igel ist eine Option, die können sie sich aussuchen. Was auch meine Geile, es gibt doch tausend so Immobilien-Serien, so Makeover und wir suchen ein neues Haus, unser Traumhaus. Das für Igel. Oder so eine Igel-Familie, die verschiedene Laubhaufen besucht, mit so einem Makler-Igel, der sagt so, ja, hier hätten wir jetzt drei Stöcke und so und so dicht. Und dann kriechen die da mal rein und sagen, oh, ist da ein bisschen wenig Platz. Und jetzt ist es ein bisschen wenig Platz, oder Schatz? Ja, weiß ich nicht, die Lage, was ist denn, wenn ein Windstoss kommt und das alles weggeweht wird? Ja, da haben sie einen Punkt. Nee, das wäre nicht übersehen. Aber da haben wir auch keine Lösung. Da haben wir generell in 2000 Jahren Igelgeschichte noch keine, wahrscheinlich länger. Also stechen die denn mit ihren Stacheln die Blätter auf, wenn die in dem Haufen sind? Nee. Nee? Nee, nee. Gar nicht. Nee, null. Das ist kein Problem.
Aber wenn ich mich jetzt als Igel in so ein Laubbett lege, stachel ich da nicht zwangsläufig auch Blätten?
Gar nicht? Ich bin völlig auf dem falschen Dampfer gerade.
Nee, weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube schon, dass es ein Problem ist und ein bisschen nervig ist.
Ich glaube aber, dass die entscheiden können, in welchem Winkel die Krallen abstehen, diese kleinen Stacheln.
Ich komme jetzt, ich komme aber, muss ich sagen, jetzt auch vom Stachelschwein gedanklich. Daher komme ich. Aus deinem normalen Forschungsumfeld, da komme ich halt her. Klar, ich komme halt vom Stachelschwein jetzt. Und ich weiß nicht, wie es andere Leute denken, die jetzt von woanders kommen. Ich komme halt vom Stachelschwein und die können halt den Winkel bestimmen. Eigentlich könnte sich so ein Igel doch mega gut tarnen, weil der kann ja auf seine Stacheln Moos und Blätter und so stecken und dann einfach komplett kamouflaget durch die Gegend. Als eigener kleiner Laubhaufen. Ja, als kleiner Laubhaufen. Der könnte ja eigentlich so eine Art Wohn... Es gibt wahrscheinlich auch so Igel, die haben eher so einen Wohnwagenvariante. Die haben kein festes Haus, sondern die haben halt einfach so einen riesigen Blätterstapel hinten auf dem Rücken drauf. jemals so ein Hüver, wie heisst das, Hilmer, diese Wohnwagenmarke, einfach hinten dran aufgespießt.
HümerHü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-Hü-H Falls du möchtest. Bleib ich dir. Immobilienshow Mieten kaufen, wohnen für Schnecken.
Das ist natürlich dann, sag ich mal, der Gagmechanismus aufs Maximum gedreht, weil die, ich erkläre es kurz, weil Schnecken ja ein festes Haus haben.
Die können sich ihr Haus ja nicht aussuchen und damit würde man die Idee einer Immobilienshow ad absurdum treiben, wenn jetzt ein Makler den Schnecken jeweils ihr eigenes Haus vorstellt und die Schnecken ja keine Wahl haben und sagen, ja, das nehme ich. Und am Ende endet die Folge mit, ja doch, mir gefällt das ganz gut, sind ja auch schon alle meine Sachen drin, ganzen Kisten im Keller, das nehme ich, Kreisblende auf diese weirden Augen
der Schnecke, also da merkt man
erstmal, ach das sind die Augen, weil die Kreisblende
zieht auf diese Fühler aus.
Vielleicht geht die Kreisblende auch erstmal falsch auf da,
wo wir die Augen zunächst vermuten würden,
um dann zu merken, ah nee.
Derjenige,
der die Kreisblende kontrolliert, ist sich
selber auch nicht so ganz sicher,
und zieht erst aufs Gesicht und dann nimmt man hoch, runter, hoch und aus. Und damit endet jede Folge. Und ja, das ist doch nett. Ja, es ist nicht schlecht. Mir gefällt auch Ad Absurdum. Ich finde, je mehr Latein in der Beschreibung eines Gags vorkommt, desto besser. Ja, ja, es ist quasi die Idee sine qua non umgesetzt. Quid pro quo führen wir hier im Sinne Art absurdum. Wollen wir mal eine Folge auf Latein machen? Ja, als ich meinen alten Lateinlehrer im Chor vorne gesehen habe, habe ich auch gedacht, ich würde gerne mal wieder Latein fliessend sprechen können wie damals. Ich konnte ja, weißt du das noch, als man in der vierten Klasse irgendwann fliessend Latein sprechen konnte? Als man sich aus dem Austausch im Vatikan vorbereitet hat, um endlich mal richtig vom Leder ziehen zu können? Antenne Agora. Was? Antenne Aqueduct, sowas in der Richtung. Können wir auch mal machen. So ein Schwachsinn. Latein war so ein Schwachsinn. Es ist unsinnig. Es ist komplett diese komischen Texte über den Limes, die ich da immer besitze. Der fucking Limes. Und auch dachte, der Limes ist halt, der Limes, weißt du, in den Asien gibt es halt die chinesische Mauer. Und du denkst, holy crap, die hat die Mongolen aufgehalten. Krass. Wir haben den fucking Limes. War Limes die einfach einen Jägerzaun? War Limes die einfach einen grössten Reinen Jägerzaun? der grösste Wall, der hier gerichtet wurde, der geht bis zu den Knien. Ja, sind wir... Was soll das sein? Wen soll das aufhalten? Da können die Hunden mit dem Skateboard drüber springen, wenn sie wollen. Das bringt doch überhaupt nichts. Es gibt mehr so... Fucking Limes, Alter, die grösste Enttäuschung der europäischen Geschichte aller Zeiten. Hm. Nee, nee, nee, Limes ist ganz weit oben. Ich baue euch einen Wall, der unser Reich beschützen wird. Das? Es klingt so, als würden sie beschissen, weil es klingt so, als hätten sie den grössten Wall der Welt quasi immer unterschrieben mit so einem stolzen Schulterklopfen, wurden aber beschissen, weil es ist natürlich der grösste, der längste, aber es ist nicht der Höchste. Das ist wie so ein Versuch. Sie hat nicht gesagt, der Höchste. Quateram derostrandum. Mea latinum finis est. Ich kann kein Latein, ich weiß nicht, was du da machst. Es klingt auch so ein bisschen wie so ein ganz windiger Versuch, ins Guinness-Buch derorde zu kommen, wie man hier hört, die grösste Pizza der Welt. Und da denkt man sich, das ist keine Pizza, da fehlt Käse oder irgendwie sowas, wo man einfach genau weiß, oder so der Käse ist nur ganz punktuell auf der Pizza und sagt, das ist keine Pizza. Und genauso sagt man auch, wir wollen ins Guinness Buch der Rekorde, längster Wall der Welt und wie hoch der ist, muss ja ja niemand wissen. Denn der Guinness-Buch-Rekorde-Redakteur steht auch da und denkt sich, ja, ist ein Wall. Ist ein Wall. Ist ein Wall. So, ich schaue noch mal nach, was unter Wall steht. Wall, Wall, Wall, Wall. Murus, Murray, Wall. Wall, eine Errichtung, um Ländergrenzen zu abhalten. Yes! Yes! Es steht im Guinness-Buch der Rekorde. Auch eine Sketch-Reihe. Guinness-Buch der Rekorde in der Antike im Riedel. Hört ihr uns doch mal zu, wir werfen euch hier Gold vor die Füsse. Wo ist fucking Tele 5 denn immer? Die hatten so tolle Sitzungen. Die haben wir, glaube ich gar nichts mehr. Dass man nicht einfach mal sagen kann, mach doch mal Guinness Buch der Rekorde in der Antike. So ein Gelangweilter, hatten wir glaube ich eh schon mal die Serie gepitcht, Redakteur bei Guinness Buch der Rekorde, der immer irgendwo rausfahren muss in so ein kleines Dorf, wo irgendjemand acht Ziegen bekommen hat, die alle aussehen wie Elvis oder so. Und er denkt sich, oh Gott, wieder so eine scheiß Elvis-Wette. Wo wir gerade übrigens bei absurden Dingen sind. Wir haben ja letzte Woche hast du von der fantastischen Serie Pulpul Molka berichtet, wo auch wenn uns ein paar HörerInnen zurückgeschrieben haben, dass es bitte nicht noch mal als Kinderserie klassifizieren solltest, weil es natürlich auch Dinge wie Raub, Überfall und Mord, Mord weiß ich nicht mehr, ehrlich gesagt. Pulpulmolka, japanische Serie, ich würde immer noch sagen Kinderserie, mit der ganz einfachen Prämisse Autos sind Meerschweinchen, also Menschen fahren in Meerschweinchen, riesigen Meerschweinchen, fahren durch die Gegend, sehr süss genug Stopp-Morchen. Trotzdem gibt es Probleme in unserer jetzigen Zeit, es wird gefickt, es wird getrunken wird geraubt. Ja, das drückst du jetzt so aus durch deinen Erwachsenenverstand, aber Kinder nehmen das natürlich anders wahr. Haben sich wirklich Fans der Serie beschwert, dass ich gesagt habe, es ist eine Kinderserie? Nee, es haben Leute gesagt, oh, eine neue spannende Kinderserie, das kann ich mir unseren Kindern zeigen, haben die den gezeigt und die Kinder waren verstört. Du hast das so verursacht. Haben die geschrien und die Eltern erstmal schön den Helm drauf, zack, kein Problem.
Sonnenbrille.
Oder kann man nicht bei Kindern einfach auch wie so Kanarienvögel, Wellensittiche, nicht einfach so eine Decke drüber werfen?
Und dann schlafen die schon ein.
Ja, das kann schon sein.
Hat das jemand versucht?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube, Eltern haben alles versucht, um ihre Kinder stillzukriegen.
Das ist so interessant bei Wellensittichen,
die schlafen sofort ein.
Es ist Nacht. Wahnsinn.
Dann so kleine Schnaken. Was passiert denn, wenn da
irgendwie mal aus Versehen Blatt
auf die fällt in der Natur?
Die schlafen einfach nie auf zu schlafen
und verhungern und tot.
Also was passiert, wenn die irgendwo
in so einem Laubhaufen fallen?
Macht es überhaupt einen Unterschied. Macht es überhaupt einen Unterschied, ob das Blatt auf uns landet und wir einfach nur noch einschlafen und dann irgendwann sterben oder ist mir eine Wellensittichstörung. Du meinst, ist es nicht schade um einen Wellensittich? Oder dass wir alle...
Ja, ich sag nur, was ist mein Leben sonst?
Was meinst du?
Würmer, ein paar Würmer, ein paar kleine Hirsenkügelchen sammeln. Das stimmt doch nicht, du hast doch so viel... Was trage ich denn da für bei? Und diese grossen Flügel, du kannst fliegen, du bist frei. Ich habe grosse, schöne, bunte Flügel, okay, okay, okay, okay, das schenke ich dir. Aber was mache ich? Was trage ich der Umwelt bei? Was der Mutter Natur? Was gebe ich Mutter Natur zurück? Die Leute freuen sich, wenn sie dich sehen. Ich lasse mal keinen Unterschied, ob ein Blatt auf mir landet und ich sterbe schlafend. Okay, gut, dann vielen Dank an den Wählen sind ich. Wir legen einmal Deckel über ihn drüber und kommen später nochmal dazu. Aber kann ja wirklich passieren. Also jetzt sind wir wieder in der Igel-Serie, die schauen sich ihre Wohnung an. Und dann fragt natürlich der besorgte Igel-Vater, wie sieht das denn mit den Nachbarn aus? Wir wollen ja auch unsere Kinder hier großziehen. Ist das denn eine gute Nachbarschaft? Und dann der Makler sagt, ja, kommt ja mal der Nachbar, Doktor Peck kommt vorbei und das ist halt Wellensittich. Wellensittig, der wird eingeladen in den Laubhaufen und der Doktor Peck sagt erstmal Dankeschön. Aber der ist wirklich ein Exot, der ist ausgebüxt, er hat wahrscheinlich auch einen besonderen Akzent. Klar, es ist ja da kein Doktortitel. Und er ist auch noch mal auf die Uni gegangen und kommt rein und dann sagen die, ja, kommen Sie doch rein und er sagt SIGNADO! Natürlich und wird eingeladen in den Laubhaufen, es ist aber stockdunkel, er schläft ein, wacht nie wieder auf. Bis die Kinder nicht in Folge Stachelfinale, Folge 18, es schaffen, ihn rauszuschieben, langsam, ohne ihre Stacheln zu benutzen. Ah genau, sie lernen nämlich, dass Nähe auch nicht immer Schmerz heißen muss. Genau, weil Nähe heisst für Igel in erster Linie erstmal Aua, Aua, Schmerz, Schmerz. Sehr naheliegende Lektion für eine Igel-Serie. Schwierig, was wir in Staffelbein noch machen. Und auch schwierig, was Kinder mitnehmen daraus, menschliche Kinder, die erstmal mitnehmen, okay, Nähe ist Schmerz. Daher habe ich meine Bindungsängste wahrscheinlich aus der Serie Po-Igel. Ich komme auch eher daher, dass ich mein Leben lang Helm getragen habe und nie menschlichen Körperkontakt gespürt habe, weil ich einen Helm anhatte die ganze Zeit. Also, glaube ich, können die da auch wieder was lernen darüber, weil die vielleicht dann Angst haben vor körperlicher Nähe und deswegen hast du die Igel-Serie, die mitgeliefert wird zu dem Helm. Also die liegt als DVD bei, dass man den Kindern die dann auch direkt zeigen kann im Helm. Problem ist, die hören nur nichts. Ja, das ist ein Problem. Also da muss man gucken, wenn sie kein Augskabel haben, wird es schwierig. Oder kann man das so machen wie diese Scheiben, man gucken kann, aber von der anderen Seite nicht, dass sie hören, also dass die Kinder... Boah, Stefan, jetzt sagst du was! ... dass die Kinder weiterhin das Weihnachtsoratorium hören. Boah, akustische Einbahnwand! Weil es ist ja gemein, das Kind hat ja gezahlt. Das Kind hat ja gezahlt fürs Weihnachtsoratorium. Jetzt macht man den Helm auf, weil es selber stört, aber dann würde man trotzdem mit einem Kind hier das Weihnachtsoratorium Erlebnis nehmen.
Warum geht das nicht? Akustische Einbahnwand. Einbahnstrassen, Akustikband. Ja? Akustische Einbahnstrassen, das wäre perfekt. A, E, S, W. Falls ihr eine solche habt oder entwickeln könnt, schreibt uns bitte. Wir brauchen neue, frische Ideen, braucht dieses Land fürs neue Jahr, wir brauchen Akustikhelme, wir brauchen Einbahn, Strassen, Akustikwände, all das meldet euch, wir sind bereit, es umzusetzen mit euch. Mit euch. Erstmal wünschen wir euch aber ganz, ganz tolle Weihnachten. Ja, geniesst es. Verbringt es in den Kreisen eurer Liebsten oder allein, ist völlig okay. Schaut euch tolle Filme an und macht euch vielleicht selber ein Geschenk. Denn die schönsten Geschenke findet ihr im Ufo-Club. Auf Patreon könnt ihr vorbeikommen, falls ihr keinen Bock mehr habt, Werbung zu hören. Dann macht euch selber mal ein Geschenk und belohnt euch für dieses tolle Jahr, denn ihr wart super. Ihr wart richtig super. Ich würde uns ein Solide 3 plus geben, aber mit Höhen und Tiefen. Tolle Community, wir haben super Intros bekommen, wir haben supergeile Grafiken aufgekommen. Ach so, stimmt. Nur hier vorbei ist letzte Folge des Jahres? Nein, doch. Doch, letzte Folge des Jahres. Vielen, vielen Dank für die ganzen Grafiken, die wir bekommen haben. Wir haben ja unser Logo geändert und haben dieses Grafikkonzept umgesetzt und hatten ein bisschen Bange, dass da vielleicht nur Crap kommt. Ich nicht, du hast gesagt, es kommt bestimmt nur Crap, ich habe gesagt, ah nein, vertrau doch auf unsere Community, die machen nur tolle Sachen. Ja, es war auch viel Crap dabei, aber auch sehr, sehr coole Designs, könnt ihr euch angucken auf Instagram oder so, da werden wir noch viel mit machen, vielen, vielen Dank für diese tollen Designs und für die tollen Intros, die sich wirklich gesteigert haben, da musste Stefan Anfang des Jahres mal ein Machtwort sprechen und musste euch mal ins Gewissen reden, aber seitdem sind wirklich tolle Intros gekommen.
Also tolles Jahr, haut rein.
Ihr wart super, vielen Dank, eine Eins plus
Sternchen für euch. Richtig gut.
Ich hoffe, wir sehen uns nächstes Jahr wieder. Bis dahin
wünschen wir euch eine schöne Zeit, erholt euch.
Kommt gut rein. Haut rein, ciao.
Und wir heben ab, macht's gut! Brrrrlllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllllll